[Music]
[Applause]
on january 19
2020 a 35 year old american man entered
an emergency health clinic in washington
state
he had been suffering from a fever and
cough for four days
meanwhile on the other side of the world
a 35 year old south korean woman had
arrived at incheon international airport
in seoul
republic of korea she had a fever chills
and muscle pain
but had been told by a doctor she merely
had a cold
both had just arrived from wuhan china
the next day january 20th both tested
positive for the novel coronavirus
the first case in each country south
korea took immediate drastic steps to
prevent the virus from spreading
the united states did not we have it
totally under control
it's one person coming in from china
it's
gonna be just fine
both south korea and the united states
had emergency plans for dealing with
epidemics
and experience fighting deadly viruses
in 2015 a south korean businessman came
down with mers
middle east respiratory syndrome after
returning from a business trip
it spread to 186 people 36 died
the government rushed to trace test and
quarantine
17 000 people a decade earlier
president george w bush was at his ranch
in crawford texas
as he read through the galley of an
upcoming book the great influenza by
historian john
m berry he was shaken by the story of a
mysterious plague that killed millions
worldwide
he feared it could happen again if we
wait for a pandemic to appear
it will be too late to prepare and one
day many lives could be needlessly lost
because we fail to act
today his administration created a
381-page
outbreak response plan president obama
used it to fight ebola in 2014
and then expanded it the plan was passed
on to donald trump's incoming
administration
they were shown a simulation of what
could happen some napped through the
presentation
and in 2018 president donald trump
disbanded the pandemic response team
in january of 2020 when south korea
detected its first coronavirus case
the country's leaders immediately got to
work their first task
develop a test and start quarantining
people right away
within a week the government and its
center for disease control sat down with
20 private research companies
less than two weeks later on february
7th the first test was approved
pharmaceutical companies immediately
began mass producing tests
the government shored up their already
large stockpile of medical equipment
because of the rapid response south
korea was able to keep many factories
shopping malls and restaurants open
through the spring
meanwhile in the united states on the
last day of 2019
alex azar the department of health and
human services secretary
got a call from the cdc azar informed
the white house national security
council about the emerging outbreak
azar formed a task force of the us's top
public health experts to prepare the
country for a worst case scenario
including dr anthony fauci the director
of the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
who had overseen the us's response to
hiv swine flu
zika and ebola their priorities medical
equipment for testing
and a quarantine strategy they drafted
plans to implement the defense
production act
where private companies are compelled to
produce equipment but the pushback from
the trump administration was immediate
while fauci and his team were working to
understand the virus and prepare the
country
azar was finding it difficult to get
guidance from the white house
azar finally got through to trump on
january 18th
the president was vacationing in
mar-a-lago and didn't want to talk about
the virus
instead he complained about nazar's
handling of a recent vaping ban
when the first patient the 35 year old
man in washington state was diagnosed
the president immediately downplayed it
we have it totally under control
it's one person coming in from china
and we have it under control it's going
to be just fine
the next day china shut down wuhan and
hubai province to contain the disease
in an email chain on january 28th carter
meecher warned
the projected size of the outbreak
already seems hard to believe
he was one of the medical advisors who
introduced the concept of
social distancing into the george w bush
pandemic plan
the national security council created
its own coronavirus task force
including azar and fauji but trump
continued to downplay the danger
he ignored requests to prioritize
testing instead taking action to keep
infected people in china
he announced the travel ban but over 300
000 people had already come to the us
from china since the start of the
outbreak
many insiders wanted more namely travel
bans to and from other countries like
italy
but treasury secretary steve mnuchin
overruled them fearing bands could
hinder the us economy and international
trade
azar worried they weren't doing enough
and asked for four billion dollars to
stockpile ventilators
masks and other equipment the budget
team was outraged and an argument broke
out in the white house situation
room on february 6 the world health
organization shipped out 250
000 coronavirus tests to various
countries
america received none because the cdc
said the u.s didn't quote
need somebody else's test but the cdc
had only shipped out 90 tests by that
point
and most of them were faulty at a black
tie event a few nights later
state governors were warned about how
bad an outbreak in the united states
could become
many of the governors were rattled by
what they heard
but earlier that day the president and
congress had cut well over a billion
dollars in cdc funding
and in new hampshire one day later trump
continued to strike an optimistic tone
looks like by april you know in theory
when it gets a little warmer it
miraculously goes away hope that's true
several days later without consulting
him first
trump's team publicly announced
recommendations to limit public
gatherings
to close schools and most offices trump
watched in anger from air force one
as the stock market plunged when he
landed on february 26
he berated azar for scaring people trump
canceled his meeting about social
distancing
he then put vice president mike pence in
charge of the white house coronavirus
response
and it was full court press by the
administration and fox news to convince
everyone there was nothing to worry
about
and this is their new hoax we have
contained this
i won't say airtight but pretty close to
air tight
this president will always put america
first he will always protect american
citizens we will not see diseases like
the coronavirus come here
now we have some on the left literally
whipping this country into a
frenzy some promoting extreme measures
immediately
close schools immediately daycare
centers businesses it's going to
disappear one day it's like a miracle it
will disappear
what is bad for america is good for
democrats it's incredible that they
think this way they root against the
stock market they root for this to take
hold
they have a demented dream of taking
down president trump it doesn't matter
how many americans they destroy
in order to get there so far we have
lost
nobody to coronavirus in the united
states
but the very next day
[Music]
washington state reported the us's first
death from covet 19.
at the beginning of march trump toured
the cdc and falsely claimed that anyone
who wanted a test could get one
every one of these doctors said how do
you know so much about this
maybe i have a natural ability maybe i
should have done that instead of running
for president
as the number of cases reported in the
u.s passed 100
trump acknowledged the epidemic in a
somber 10-minute televised address that
night
it only matters how you respond and we
are responding with great speed and
professionalism
this is the most aggressive and
comprehensive effort to confront a
foreign virus in modern history
the government's race to secure tests
and medical equipment began on march
13th
when trump declared a national emergency
by this point the u.s was months behind
other countries
trump announced social distancing
guidelines on march 16th
meant to last two weeks but he wanted to
roll them back earlier
his closest advisors argued with him
saying it was unrealistic
he contradicted his own experts daily
sometimes within minutes
we have stockpiled hydroxy chloroquine
critics said he still was not taking the
pandemic seriously i've always known
this is a pandemic
i felt it was a pandemic long before it
was called a pandemic
by the beginning of april south korea
emerged from isolation and was heading
back to normal
many businesses reopened even more
restaurants and cafes were bustling
meanwhile in the united states the virus
was still spreading
the country was largely shut down and
unemployment numbers hit record highs
the u.s was well on its way to leading
the world in coronavirus cases
and yet the nation began to reopen
through the summer and fall
if the us had managed to keep its death
rate the same as south korea's
fewer than 3 000 people would have died
by october 1st
instead the death toll reached over 200
000. and on october 2nd
president trump announced that he had
contracted the virus